i have to ask you this is so random and
i think the internet was surprised by it
this chris evans tweet about how your
name
is just totally your name you wound up
trending on twitter for 24 hours over it
did you see it what is your your
reaction to that tweet
uh you know it's amazing the uh
the power of the internet uh i i thought
it definitely came out of the blue
uh came out of nowhere oh mr slater
this is just a delicious show isn't it
oh boy
it was it was definitely fun to sink my
teeth into i had a great time
well i look i'm going to be honest with
you my first question for you is going
to be
i i would have said christian slater's
probably going to play the bad guy on
this show
right was this uh something you wanted
to avoid were you originally offered
that role you tell me
you know i i was immediately attracted
to the role of dr kirby
um you're right i i i feel the same way
dr death would be typically the
character that you would see me playing
and
and uh this was an opportunity to to
to try something else and do something
else so it was fun to to get the chance
to play somebody
heroic and and on the right side of the
law this time that was
uh that was unusual and i really
appreciated it
all due respect dr kirby you don't
understand the law
you don't understand who we're after did
you need a bad guy break
uh let's see if i did well you know i
had just done the dirty john
betty broderick story where i played
just a horrible horrible husband who was
you know manipulating his wife all the
way
through and um you know that was you
know
some of those roles they're difficult to
play they're they're hard to play so i
always try and do them with a little bit
of a sense of humor while i'm while i'm
making the shows
um but this one the the humor
and the charm you know the the the charm
of the real guy
um i recently got to meet dr kirby and
and uh you know he is
extraordinarily energetic and very
passionate and
i think dr kirby and dr henderson are
genuine heroes you know they were really
willing to put their careers on the line
uh to do the right thing and and stop a
psychopath from uh
operating on human beings i swear i will
make sure this never happens to anyone
else it's i mean i was gonna ask you how
much research you did i i was a fan of
this podcast
did you podcast before you signed on
yeah
yeah i uh i listened to the podcast i
felt that it was definitely a
great story to be told on television and
um
you know would be a great miniseries and
it all just started to come together
uh but like i said i was interested in
kirby from the get-go and
and uh i really liked his energy and i
liked his
his passion and his uh enthusiasm and
also the opportunity to work with
somebody like alec baldwin and
kind of play off of him and uh you know
the other great thing is
is uh patrick mcmanus the show runner
was more
willing to allow us to uh you know just
have fun with it
and improvise a little bit more um kirby
needed to be
somewhat unpredictable which uh i tried
to bring to the role
well i mean your signature charm is in
there that that
first the scene in the first episode
when you're in the or and you're talking
about the car and everything i'm like
you're just the best so much the system
is broken
i have a suggestion it's a bit extreme
so what uh what was it like for you to
get to work with alec baldwin
you guys are actually i could see both
of you in the more villainous roles so
it feels like you're both
doing a little something different here
yeah well he you know famous for some of
his
roles of course and uh malice i believe
was the movie where he played a doctor
that was an egomaniac and also probably
a psychopath in
a large degree so been there done that
yeah so it was an opportunity for both
of us to uh
do something different and and see how
it would go and
you know it's it's always funny when a
creator a writer is is open-minded
enough to um
to give somebody that chance and you
know
people are at times pleasantly surprised
i'm glad that they are in this
circumstance
now these three parts are all really
great
when you're in the scenes are you ever
just as an actor thinking oh i would
have loved to
have been able to deliver that line or
here's how i would have done it
uh no no
we're so individual and i really think
very well thought out
that um that i never really felt
um that i wanted to deliver anybody
else's lines
uh you know working with joshua jackson
was
a hilarious experience of course he and
i were really only in one scene together
for most of the
the show we're in pursuit of this guy so
um but seeing his total lack of
uh ability um i think was pretty genuine
you know it was i think probably on the
same level as uh
dr dunch so those moments um
behind the scenes were quite as
horrifying as they were
were quite humorous did you have to do
any research and i know sometimes it's
hard to remember all these medical terms
you know when people work on these shows
they're like
we don't even know what we're saying but
we gotta say it yeah i mean what's a
needle nose ronjour i had no idea
but i was very fortunate that i have a
brother-in-law
who's a vascular surgeon so i was able
to go
in and uh you know actually watch and
and see some of the surgeries and i
scrubbed in
and they put me in the outfit and uh so
i really did get to have that experience
and we also had technical you know
doctors on the set that were very
helpful
okay dr slater are you ready to operate
i uh
you know i i did more in there than i
probably should have but
we'll we'll keep that between us by the
way speaking of your name i have to ask
you this is so random and i think the
internet was surprised by
it this chris evans tweet
about how your name is just totally your
name you wound up
trending on twitter for 24 hours over it
did you see it what is your
your reaction to that tweet uh you know
it's amazing the uh the power of the
internet
uh i i thought it definitely came out of
the blue
uh came out of nowhere i don't know
where chris evans was at that particular
moment but
uh you mean mentally yeah you know i i
don't know what was going on but
you know someday hopefully he and i will
get the opportunity to sit down and and
uh and discuss this do you guys know
each other
no not not at all you know this was
completely out of the blue
um uh but very funny and very
interesting and it was
uh you know i did check it out a little
bit and it was funny to see some of the
comments
and uh you know i don't think i'd ever
trended on twitter before so it was i
you know i have a 19 year old daughter
so i had to kind of go to her and ask
her what was going on
well she probably thought it was pretty
cool captain america was tweeting about
dad
he uh she she was when she saw that it
was trending she was like oh wait
you know this is this is quite
incredible do you agree that your name
is
the only name you could ever have i
believe so
uh you know my my father and mother were
very specific
about uh the name that they chose for me
and and
uh i hope that i have done it justice i
think you have
i gotta rap with you but really quick we
we just wanted to uh honor and recognize
this year's the 35th anniversary of one
of your first movies
uh the name of the rose with the uh the
late great sean connery
uh do you have any favorite memories of
working with him
on that film what what a guy to learn
from yeah i mean nothing but
um to get the opportunity to work with
somebody like that
and to have a a career foundation like
that
i i don't know i was 16 15 16 at the
time and
and uh i don't know if i necessarily
understood
how amazing of an opportunity that was i
i
i loved it um to get to be around him
was
was remarkable to see what a
professional and what a man he
he was uh i miss him greatly uh
he was definitely a hero of mine and
remains that today
well here you are 35 years later killing
it on your new show
uh thank you so much the show is awesome
congrats on everything
oh thanks so much
you